TV is better than it's ever been and
with that explosion in choice and
quality comes a quantity of incredible
performances here are the actors whose
performances go beyond great and are
perfectly flawless the three short years
from 2013 and 2015 were a magical era in
entertainment rising from the ashes of
crappy romantic comedies and punchlines
about how often he could be spotted
shirtless Matthew McConaughey uttered in
the Makana sense it was a career
reinvention in which he proved himself a
compelling leading man who could
disappear into any role without even
ditching his thick Texas accent while
the film Dallas buyers club may have
been the one that scored him an Oscar
and interstellar marked the most
high-profile film of that era there's no
role he took during that era that has
the cultural impact of rust coal from
the HBO series true detective Cole is a
bleak nihilistic detective worn down
from years of undercover work loss and
substance abuse he never gives a
straight answer to any question managing
to turn something as simple as how do
you sleep into a riddle
he's simultaneously obnoxious and
endearing despite sounding like a 15
year old who's just seen Fight Club for
the first time your master laugh
maybe McConaughey excels in the role
playing off Woody Harrelson who co-stars
as Cole's partner Marty with Odd Couple
chemistry Cole could read as parody if
not for the nuanced McConaughey brings
to the role any future true detective
actors have big shoes to fill
anyone who has a complicated
relationship with a family member is
going to find Netflix's bloodline way
too real to get through it in a single
sitting the show analyzes the complex
family dynamics between parents siblings
and extended family in an
extraordinarily raw fashion there's no
poor acting in the series and Kyle
Chandler is truly exceptional as John
the patriarch of the Rayburn family that
said nobody knocks it out of the park
quite like ben mendelsohn as Danny the
black sheep of the family
Danny's arrival in the show's pilot
signals a proverbial storm on the
horizon he's effectively been
excommunicated from the Rayburn clan and
it quickly becomes clear why he's wild
and not in the sense of a constantly
partying frat boy he's more like a live
wire dangling over running water it
doesn't take much to set him off and
when that happens something's going to
be burned to the ground
Mendelssohn's portrayal is darkly
charismatic and very careful in its
steps a necessity considering Danny's
tendency to pivot sharply from friendly
to terrifying in a matter of seconds
those turns never seem unbelievable
thanks to the care Mendelssohn puts into
the role his avatar of chaos is a true
standout not just for this show but for
the entirety of Netflix's original
content bloodlines is very good overall
but Mendelssohn's performance is what
makes it can't miss binge television
show times penny dreadful probably could
have had a decade-long run if it merely
stuck to its roots in gothic horror and
fantasy playing up the poppier elements
of its source material the show revolved
around a fictional universe in which
Victorian horror icons such as Dorian
Gray and Victor Frankenstein exist in
the same world a winning formula for a
19th century version of supernatural
instead the show chose to become
thing more it cast a crew of exceptional
British actors and played up the
Shakespearean overtones of its story
elevating the artistic integrity of its
genre roots to the forefront while the
whole cast is exceptional
former James Bond actor Timothy Dalton
is especially good as an ex adventurer
Malcolm Murray the standout is easily
ava Green as Vanessa Vanessa is a woman
whose entire life has been surrounded by
darkness by otherworldly forces seeking
to use her to their whims but her
strength lies in her constant refusal to
be anything but a bright light in her
dark world you could argue for Green's
excellence in the role based solely on
the extent to which she seems to
disregard her own physical well-being
for the sake of performance
Vanessa goes through several drastic
physical transformations and a scene
involving a seance sees her contorting
her body gruesomely however to focus on
her physical commitment would be to sell
short the empathy and tenderness Green
instills into Vanessa very few
characters in this mold have felt so
undeniably human penny dreadful is all
the better for it there aren't a lot of
comedies that have balanced a gradual
transition from conventional to bizarre
quite like new girl over the course of
its run it transformed from a quirky
Zooey Deschanel vehicle to a truly
out-there comedy about some of the
strangest characters on TV few
characters embody that evolution quite
like Nick Miller play to perfection by
Jake Johnson you ought to be a long old
truck or the family how the family would
be in Montana or or Mars landing you
know if the government finally steps up
Nick enters the series as a comedic
straight man pretty conventional and
clearly set up to be the Ross to
Deschanel's Rachel his neuroses and
quirks are dealt out slowly over the
first two seasons and by the time season
4 begins he's a full-on nutcase and a
pretty endearing one at that he's an
emotionally stunted conspiracy theorist
whose best friend is a silent man he
talks to on a park bench Johnson
embodies Nick perfectly especially
shining when doing or saying something
ridiculous that Nick clearly believes is
entirely normal he brings a great deal
of heart to the role that keeps Nick
and it even when he's going off about
his distrust of banks and cell phones
taking a character from a normal place
to such a weird one is tricky to pull
off for a writers room luckily they had
Johnson to anchor the character and make
it all work in the wake of get out and
black panther it's easy to forget we're
now superstar actor Daniel Kuya got one
of his first major exposures to American
audiences an early episode of the
pessimistic sci-fi anthology black
mirror
Kaluga appears in the series second ever
episode titled 50 million merits and
it's a performance that shows exactly
why he rocketed to worldwide fame
shortly after this was something real
time
just once each episode of the show
explores the disquieting implications of
an aspect of technology or media in this
case the story revolves around a sort of
twisted reality show in a dystopian and
close-quarters world in which the only
way one can rise from their societal
rank as a grunt working an exercise bike
all day is to win an American Idol ask
gameshow we explore this world through a
character named Bing and follow his
romance with a fellow biker only to see
her sucked into the world of this
reality show it's an almost
Shakespearean tragedy and being played
by Cal Ouya is among black mirrors most
memorable characters we follow him from
frustration to elation elation to love
love to heartbreak and heartbreak to an
unending seething rage it's a difficult
character arc to tackle especially in a
single episode of high concept
television but coleus chops are clearly
up to the task when it comes to the
all-time greats of superhero casting
sure Chris Evans and Robert Downey jr.
are great but they've got small screen
competition Krysten Ritter as Jessica
Jones in the Netflix show of the same
name definitely belongs on the list of
all-time great superhero casting it's
all the more impressive when you realize
that Jones is unlike any other
protagonist viewers have seen in the
genre and Ritter delivers an incredible
TV performance to do it proper justice
Jessica Jones has superpowers but she's
no Avenger I gave it a shot once tell me
there was a costume when you still got
it
it didn't work out instead she's a
private investigator a combination of
every detective novel stereotype with
the addition of superhuman strength and
a few other cool powers when we meet her
we see a different kind of Marvel hero a
victim of abuse at the hands of a
sadistic villain who used mind control
to bend her to his winds Britta is
dealing with emotions and traumas that
are incredibly real ones that viewers of
the show are far more likely to have
experienced themselves than those of
Thor or Captain America as such Britta
pairs a great deal of responsibility in
performing this role and she handles it
with poise and grace masterfully
navigating Jessica through a multitude
of complex emotional highs and lows it
also definitely doesn't hurt that she's
great at sardonically quipping her way
through every confrontation with a bad
guy that comes her way if true detective
is HBO's effort to showcase the skill of
two massively talented male actors big
little lies is their effort to do the
same for a group of some of the most
talented female actors on the planet
every woman on the show is tremendous
from Laura Dern to Nicole Kidman
but Reese Witherspoon's performance is
perhaps the most memorable as Madeline
Witherspoon is a seemingly simple
character with a wealth of complications
beneath her surface she's a woman with
an all too real desire to convince her
neighbors and family that everything is
fine Madeline is on her second marriage
and struggling with raising an older
daughter who's in the dregs of her
teenage years and a younger daughter
who's already too perceptive for her own
good she constantly runs into her ex who
parades around town with his new younger
wife clearly looking to rub it in
Madeline space oh I'm loved there oh
thank you I made it in crew course you
did Witherspoon channels the defensive
combative bluster into Madeline and
abrasiveness that keeps people at two
greater distance to see how close she is
to crumbling it's a remarkable
performance in a show already chock full
of them when Hollywood came calling with
roles in blockbusters like Pacific Rim
and Marvel's Thor films Idris Elba
easily could have stepped away from his
role as police detective John Luther in
the BBC series Luther
hasn't the show has amidst Elvis ascent
as a movie draw continued on a clear
testament to how much he enjoys playing
the character it makes perfect sense as
the Luthor is by far the most compelling
role he's ever taken on and a forum for
some of the most consistently great work
of his career John Luther is a bull in a
china shop he's a ruthless violent
detective with intense anger issues and
a disregard for any authority that isn't
his he'd probably be a villain if he
weren't so dang cool that might be
what's so impressive about Elvis
performances Luther in addition to
tackling such a wide array of dark
emotions he never forgets to make Luther
the coolest cop on TV from his icy
demeanor to his trademark tweed jacket
you can't help but want to be him save
his anger management issues in constant
barrage of tragedy that is it's been a
long time since the era of bonanza and
Gunsmoke had westerns ruling the TV
airwaves but make no mistake American
audiences still love a good cowboy the
fewer and further between these days but
there's nothing like a TV show about a
straight-up old-school gunslinger no
show has updated that classic archetype
to the modern era quite as well as
justified which features Timothy
Olyphant as Raylan Givens a u.s. marshal
whose cowboy ways don't stop at his hat
and sub and rule why don't you
understand I don't pull my sidearm less
I'm going to shoot to kill that's his
purpose huh to kill so how I use it the
show follows Raylan originally created
by legendary crime novelist Elmore
Leonard as he's forced to relocate to
his hometown of Harlan Kentucky after a
shootout gone wrong in Miami aside from
taking on criminals of all sorts
Raylan is confronted with old friends
enemies and family ties he's made every
effort to escape since leaving
underneath the cowboy cool demeanor and
quick-draw Oliphant instills a simmering
anger in Raylan one that's amplified by
how well Oliphant performs the
characters quieter moments we love a
classic western shootout but Raylan is
never more engaging than he is when
talking to his ex-wife his antagonist
Boyd played immaculately by Walton
Goggins or confronting his father
elephant brings equal charisma and
empathy to a character that
could be a one-note gunslinger instead
he delivers one of the most memorable TV
performances and easily the greatest
cowboy character of televisions modern
era check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bowl so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]